[Applause]
thank you
we are a president they are Ursula they
are students participants of the
European diplomatic Academy it is for me
really an honor a pleasure an emotion I
would say to welcome the president of
the European commission with us uh when
I heard of this possibility just a few
days ago I was really excited about this
and even if normally during the exam
session we avoid distracting you uh we
thought that this was an excellent
destruction
and an opportunity not to be missed and
I was impressed and I shared this with
the president that in six minutes you
all registered at 8pm so it means that
you were on your laptops which means you
were studying probably but it also means
that you understood why you're here
you're here to study and to study hard
and by the way good luck for your exams
your ongoing session uh some of most
most of you have exams tomorrow too so
good luck for that you're here to study
Europe but you're also here to leave
Europe and to experience how it is that
institutions shape the policies
in some cases we're lucky enough to give
some hints of some contributions some
ideas uh
but I think this is an excellent
opportunity to see the policy making in
the making and we are honored today to
listen from the president of the
European commission
how Europe's competitiveness is going to
develop in a new context
accelerating the green transition with a
strong industrial base which is
something quite complex to tackle but so
important for our continent in the
present and in the future I'm very
excited to have today with us the
President also on a personal level for
me it's a pleasure always to see you
again we shared so many important
moments in a couple of lives ago and I
can testimony anytime over dedication
for wisdom the energy that she puts in
everything she does and I always tell
her when we have the occasion when I
have the pleasure to meet her that I am
always glad and relieved to know that in
these difficult times we have someone
like her like leading the European
commission so also place the Flores
yourself thank you for being here with
us
foreign
promotion
and dear young diplomats and most of all
thank you very much dear Federica
um thank you very much for making it
possible that I speak here today and
that you invited me and let me thank you
very much for what you're doing here in
Bruges
because indeed when we first met you
were the high representative I was the
German defense minister there was
something that struck me immediately
meeting you and speaking to you because
besides the day-to-day crisis that you
had to manage
you were almost always somebody who
tried to focus on the long-term
strategic thinking that was always
important for you and you always thought
that Europe needed a common strategic
culture and in the very end it resulted
in the global strategy that you
developed it was a process to help a
European thinking emerge and it led to
very practical steps towards a common
European Defense basis that we worked on
together now you're doing the same here
in Bruges with young men and women from
across Europe and with young diplomats
from all member states and Beyond and I
really want to congratulate you the
young students here in this pilot and
all the participants of the European
diplomatic Academy because you are
basically the future of the European
foreign policy
so many thanks for having me here today
what we need is indeed strategic
thinking more than ever
because we are in difficult times
and these leads of course to difficult
questions
what is Europe's strategic goal
what should our economy look like in the
2030s and Beyond what is our growth
strategy
what are the challenges to address in
the short term the midterm and the long
term
there's one common feature
in answering
all these questions
and that is without any doubt the big
topic of climate change
its consequences will come in all shapes
and all forms
and it is the most existential threat
and issue we all face
this is why the European Union has a
very clear road map for this challenge
you all know it's called our European
green deal
it is our new and sustainable growth
strategy
and when we set off
we knew that the road would not always
be smooth
that as the global setting around us
is constantly changing
we would have to constantly adapt to
stay the course
but let me tell you we did not know how
bumpy this road would be
we had a pandemic with aftershocks that
are still being felt around the world
across the world
business business has a tough time to
really
catch up again after this pandemic and
the lockdowns Russia Unleashed an
unprovoked unjustified brutal atrocious
war against Ukraine
and the spillover effects are Global
from energy supply to the redrawing of
global diplomacy
and now and that's the reason why I'm
here today we see in parallel that we
are confronted with an intensifying
Global clean tech race
in tackling all these new challenges
we always have to keep in mind the
direction of our travel
it is towards a thriving
a clean and a competitive European
economy
and this is what I want to talk about
today to you
if we want to speak about that let us
first zoom out a little bit
and bring you back in time a few years
it is exactly three years ago that we
launched the European green deal
it was the very beginning of my mandate
as president of the European Commission
and we decided that our first priority
would be
to decarbonize
and digitalize the European economy
I called it our man in the moon moment
and it was really moonshot
we were the first Global power to set
the path towards net zero emissions
and to make it legally binding
you might remember at that time we had
in the United States an Administration
in place that did not believe that
humans caused climate change
and announced to pull out of the Paris
agreement
China was heavily investing in coal
and Europe emerged as a global
front-runner
we said to ourselves let's not wait to
do what is right
let's invest today
in the clean Technologies of tomorrow
because eventually if we do it right all
advanced and emerging eCommerce
economies will embark on the same
Journey
and we've stayed the course ever since
this has given certainty it has given
certainty to our industry to our
investors on the direction of travel
we have cast our goals in the first ever
climate law
when the pandemic hit we created Next
Generation EU not only to power the
recovery that was also important
but also to accelerate the
digitalization and the European green
deal
just keep in mind that almost half of
Next Generation you this is our 800
billion recovery plan half of it
contributes to a wider climate
objectives
we developed a legal framework to cut
emissions by at least 55 percent
and in parallel we have worked with
industry and strategic fields from joint
European projects on batteries or
hydrogen to the European ships Act
Europe has become the Global Hub of
investment for cleantech and
decarbonization
now if you now fast forward to today
first of all there is some positive news
Europe is no longer alone in the fight
against climate change
when President Biden came into office
one of his first decisions was to rejoin
the Paris agreement
and now the United States has taken the
next step
and passed the inflation reduction Act
and the bipartisan infrastructure law
the inflation reduction act called IRA
is an investment plan of roughly
369 billion dollars
to build up a new industrial ecosystem
in strategic clean energy sectors
and there is a striking symmetry
between the inflation reduction Act
and our European green deal
both of them
are simultaneously
a climate strategy
and a strategy for investment and growth
both of them
include funding for just transition
and both of them include regulatory
standards so we have the two biggest and
most advanced economies in the world
that are now moving in the same
direction
the United States relies traditionally
on investment and Regulatory standards
while we the European Union relies on a
combination
of investment and Regulatory standards
and carbon pricing
two continent-sized powers
a modernizing the economies
by investing close to a trillion euros
and addressing together the biggest
challenges of our times and this is so
important
it is not only a positive signal for our
planet
but also for our Global Investors
yet
the inflation reduction Act is also
raising concerns
here in Europe
against a very particular backdrop for
our industry and economy
the first point is that covet has
exacerbated bottlenecks in many critical
Supply chains
the European industry has been carefully
trying to fix the weak Links of these
change in the last weeks and months and
make them more resilient
but of course this has come at a cost
the second element you are very familiar
with
that is the global energy Supply is
tight
because of Russia's war of aggression
you know it from the European Union just
think of the fact that in the last eight
months only Russia has cut 80 percent of
the pipeline gas supply to the European
Union
but and this is important
we've been able to compensate
something that is truly remarkable
eighty percent of the pipeline gas
supply in eight months
it is remarkable and it deemed
impossible to many
but we should keep in mind in these
eight months there have been not only no
blackouts in the European Union
but we also managed to fill our gas
storages by almost 96 so we are safe for
this winter
but this comes also
at a higher cost of energy for our
industry and our smes
and all of this
affects the competitiveness
of many European Industries especially
energy intensive sectors of our economy
it is against this spectrop
that the inflation reduction Act
has received so much additional scrutiny
in Europe and also in the rest of the
world
there's a risk
that the IRA
can lead to unfair competition
could close markets
and that's fragment the very same
critical Supply chains that have already
been tested by covet
so we need to look at these issues
closely and at the same time learn what
we can do better
and in doing so we need to look at three
aspects that are particularly
challenging in the ira
the first one is
by American
this by American logic
underpins part of the IRA
second difficult issue is tax breaks
that could lead to discrimination some
get them others not
and the search element is production
subsidies
that could lead to a subsidies race
now this sounds all very technical
but it's easier to understand if I give
you one example
if you are a consumer in the United
States
you get a tax break when you buy
electric vehicles EVS
if they were manufactured in North
America
and if you are a battery producer
for those same electric vehicles
you get a tax break if you produce in
the United States
so you get the essence this means that a
car manufacturer gets a double benefit
for producing in North America
and for buying parts in the United
States
and what is more is that this could also
attract critical components and raw
materials towards the United States and
away from the transatlantic Supply
chains
and you can imagine this creates of
course
first of all an attractive conducive
investment environment on clean tech in
the United States
but we already see how this could also
affect Europe's own clean tech Base by
redirecting investment flows
and we've all heard the stories of
producers that are considering to
relocate future investments from the
European Union to the United States
now I want to be very clear on one point
competition is good
we like it it's important
it drives innovation
it enhances efficiency
it ensures progress
and in doing so it brings down prices
for clean Technologies
competition between Europe and the
United States can push both our
Industries to excel
to innovate to transform faster and all
this is necessary
and this is why I believe in the need to
invest into two clean energy industrial
bases on both sides of the Atlantic
that is so important that we see the
Dual approach not only will we create
the well-paid jobs of the future if we
do so both in the European Union and in
the United States
but we will also drive through this
competition down costs for clean energy
Technologies globally
so together the United States and the
European Union we can make clean energy
more affordable worldwide if we work
together
and by doing so
we will help of course decarbonize
other economies
and drive a just transition
but
you expected a butt in all this
but this competition must respect a
Level Playing Field
and that's why it is so critical
that the technology competition between
the European Union and the United States
is a race to the top for our Industries
on both sides of the Atlantic
and I'm confident that Europe is in a
strong position to compete on global
markets
and develop the clean Technologies of
tomorrow
now will this be enough to keep up the
clean tech race
yes if we are competing
on a Level Playing Field
so we must take action to rebalance the
playing field where the IRA and other
measures create distortions
in other words
we need to do our homework here in
Europe
and at the same time we have to work
with the United States
to mitigate competitive disadvantages
and I see three ways to do so
the first is
we have to adjust our own rules to
facilitate public investment into the
transition
the second
we have to reassess the need for further
European funding of this transition
and thirdly
we have to work with the United States
to address some of the most concerning
aspects of their law
to my first point
as I said we have to adjust our own
rules to make it easier for public
investment to power this transition
State eight State eight is a tried and
tested to World here in Europe
and it incentivizes business activities
for the public interest
just to give you an example last summer
we approved 4.4 billion euros 5.4
billion euros in state 8 for the
hydrogen valid chain
under one of our so-called ipcis you
know the abbreviations important
projects of common European interest
this public investment will benefit 35
companies
from 15 different member States from
Portugal to Denmark from Finland to
Italy
and they will help bring new
technologies from the laboratory to the
factory for hydrogen production for
powered trucks for storage for hydrogen
trains or hydrogen-powered ships
and this is only one of the many
examples of our stated policy at the
service of cleantech
yet the inflection inflation reduction
act should make us reflect
on how we can improve our state aid
framework
and adapt it
to a new global environment
so we must look at how we can make our
framework more predictable
and more simple
Europe as you know has built a very
sophisticated system
but business today is asking for simple
system and simple rules
Europe has built a very precise system
but business today once stayed at rules
to be predictable above all
we are very careful to avoid distortions
in our single Market it's very important
but we also must be responsive to the
increasing Global competition on
cleantech so we have to look at the
global market
and if you look at the inflation
reduction Act
it invests right along the value chain
in some strategic sectors
and this is not always the case with our
state aid
our ipcis for example aim to bring
breakthrough Technologies from the
laboratory to their first industrial
deployment that is good
but we now will also take a fresh look
at how we can support the whole value
chain
down to the mass production of the most
strategic Green Tech Solutions
and clean end products
including through public investment
our stated framework exists to preserve
our very precious single Market
but if we see that investment in
strategic sectors
are leaking away from the European Union
this would only undermine our single
market and that is why
we are now reflecting on how to simplify
and adapt our state aid rules
my second point
my second Point has to do with the
complementary European funding
while it is critical that member states
have the flexibility to invest their
budgets in strategic sectors
this approach cannot be self-standing
because you can imagine if it's only
about State 8
it would of course favor those member
states that have Deep Pockets the fiscal
space
and that would lead to Distortion of our
single market and would eventually
undermine our single Market
thus we also need a common European
answer to the challenge both in the
short term and in the long term
and in the short term
what we have to do is we have to bridge
the difficult time for our smes and
industries right now
to transition to transition towards
cheaper and renewable energy all across
the European Union at the moment being
they're stuck in this energy crunch with
expensive fossil fuels and we have to
support them or Bridge the time so that
they can transform and transition
towards renewable energy that is the
cheap energy the Homegrown and
affordable energy
and here repower EU is our tool
repower issue we are just having it in
the final negotiations in Parliament and
Council to be approved till the end of
the year
repower EU invests in Energy Efficiency
in renewable energy massively
and in the infrastructure that you need
to integrate their European Union the
interconnectors the grid for example
and what is important
repower EU will massively speed up the
permitting process for renewable energy
processes projects
you might know that sometimes these
projects needs seven to eight years to
be permitted so our ambition is now to
reduce that to below one year to really
have all these energy renewable energy
projects that are on the pipeline up and
running
we are now working
on boosting
repower issue
repower EU needs greater Firepower
to accelerate exactly this green
transition however
we also need to look Beyond ad hoc
Solutions
the new assertive industrial policy of
our competitors
needs a structural answer from the
European Union
and in my State of the Union Address
I introduced the idea of establishing a
sovereignty fund
the logic behind the sovereignty fund is
simple
we need a common European industrial
policy and this common European
industrial policy requires common
European funding
the goal of our European industrial
policy
is for European industry to be the
leaders in the clean tech transition
and this means over the midterm
that we have to beef up the resources
available
for Upstream research for innovation
and for strategic projects at the
European Union's level
in other words
this means on one hand
new and additional funding at the EU
level
and it means on the other hand
higher level of policy coordination like
hydrogen like semiconductors Quantum
Computing artificial intelligence
biotechnology all these important topics
and on my third and final point
cooperation
instead of Confrontation
we are working very closely with the
Biden Administration on how to jointly
strengthen strengthen our clean energy
industrial base
and let me go back to the example I gave
you earlier the electric vehicles the
EVS
in Europe we have just agreed to phase
out the combustion engine by 2035.
this means new vehicles sold after 2035
will be exclusively Electric
similar regulatory commitments exist in
the United States
and at the same time
China is subsidizing massively this
sector
so we the United States and the European
Union have a vast common interest to
preserve our industrial leadership
and this will require fundamental
changes in the automobile industry
it will require significant private and
public investments in innovation in
infrastructure in Supply chains and raw
materials on both sides of the Atlantic
but it is not just about investment
it is also about setting standards and
joining forces where it makes sense
take for example the whole topic of the
charging infrastructure for EVS
if Europe and the United States agree on
common standards
it is us who will shape Global standards
and not leave it to others
or take the topic of critical raw
materials for cleantech that we urgently
need
today the production and processing of
some of these critical raw materials
without them no green transition
today the processing and production
is basically controlled by one single
country
and that is China
Europe and the United States can build
an alternative to this Monopoly we see
by establishing a critical raw materials
Club
the idea behind it is simple
it is cooperation with partners and
allies
on the sourcing on the production on the
processing
that gives us the ability to overcome
this Monopoly
so there you have two examples of
standards
or the raw materials
to give you an idea what we are working
on with the White House exactly right
now
and finally
all this should be seen in a wider
context
let us zoom out again and focus on the
bigger picture
an aggressive Russia is threatening our
democracies
and is blackmailing us with our
dependency on fossil fuels
an increasingly assertive China
is cultivating dependencies in all
continents
to project power of its own interests
but by contrast
look at what the United States and
Europe are able to achieve if we join
forces
take Ukraine
think of the immense impact of our
sanctions
think of how much support we have
mobilized together
from our countries and the world
to help Ukraine in the last nine months
this Brave and courageous people
look at us joining forces to dry out
Russia's War chest
by just now introducing a Russian oil
price cap globally
let me tell you that since the end of
the Cold War never never has the
transatlantic Corporation been closer
as in those two last years
we have ended long-standing disputes on
steel tariffs on Airbus Boeing on
securing data flows
we have created a tech and trade Council
to cooperate on Tech and trade mattress
we have set up this spring a task force
on European energy security
that led to additional deliveries of 15
billion cubic meters of LNG this year
and remember I told you that 80 of the
pipeline gas has been cut
so in the first half of 2022
the United States supplied more than
three quarters three quarters of the
eu's additional needs
and on climate
we have brought together over 100
countries to sign the global methane
pledge
a commitment to cut Global methane
emissions by 30 percent in this decade
these are just examples what we are able
to do if we join forces the power of
transatlantic partnership
and therefore these students
ladies and gentlemen
this is my message to you
as you embark on this journey
at the European diplomatic Academy or
students here in Borussia
there will always be times
where new challenges emerge
and old tensions
rise back to the surface
this can be the case with rivals
and competitive
or even with your oldest and closest
partners
but as you will learn in this next year
Europe will always look for Solutions
solutions that are crafted by
cooperation
and designed by diplomacy
and of course Europe always do what is
right for Europe
so yes the European Union will respond
in an adequate and well-calibrated
manner to the inflation reduction Act
but does this mean that we will engage
in a costly trade war with the United
States in the middle of an actual War
this is not in our interest
and nor in the interest of The Americans
and it would harm Global Innovation too
so that is the reason why we're working
so hard in Europe and the United States
now
to exactly precisely address these
distortions
in the last two years
the EU and the United States have shown
that we are stronger individually
When We Stand Together collectively
when we focus on what binds us
our values
our friendship
our belief in fear competition
our belief in open markets
and of course our belief and commitment
to the rules-based order
for friends like us
competition and cooperation can be two
phases of the same coin
so let us strengthen clean investment on
both sides of the Atlantic
let us do it for our people
for Industries
of course for affordable clean energy
worldwide
and for the sake of our planet thank you
very much for listening and Long Live
Europe
foreign